えっと今日は弾み佐々ですこういうニュースがあったんですよ挑戦者も東部ボリューム
満点な超特大サイズ受けたマックスがラーメンになってとうぞ
醤油辛味噌すぐ送りましたこの記事見出しがすぐ送りました dm 翌日送らせて
もらいますは秋がとうございます本日発送しました明日には届くと思います
ボリュームや梅など気をつけてくださいありがとうございます
というわけで実物こちらこれが辛味噌でこっちがちょ醤油ラーメンでございます
ちょっとまあ実物画像でしか見てないからどんなもんなのか全くわかんないんで4つも
黙って聞いたらモールちょっと怖いをですね
大丈夫これちょっと待って待ってますよあ
[音楽]
8 a
どーんサッカーってカーちょちょちょちょちょー応募にペタ max 醤油ラーメンと
鼻味噌ラーメンでございます大きさがおかしいでしょもう絶対に一人で食べないで
ください
これは不利なのかフリーではないのかという意味でぱっと見何かめちゃくちゃいい感じ
のプリン動作
れてるんですけども39905キロカロリー
全協力91kcal 水は2200ml に切っトレード必要ですてやんさん
やりましたねありがとうございます動画的にありがとうございますなんですけども
これはまたやばいを出しましたね弁花や木様だったんですけども今回何人ということで
もうやばい
じゃあ辛味噌ラーメンのカロリー見たら今陽線197kcal こっちのほうが
ちょっとだけ頭高いですえーっと固定します寝させ屋に2つ空のは本当に無理で合計車
8000距離カロリー本当に人間として無理だと思うんで辛いの苦手なんでこん
1醤油ラーメンでかせていただきますいやペアんでさぁの申しあげないですの前回
もう一個5首からの担々麺出てたんですよ担々麺の方にが者アーム効果で連絡いただい
ていたんですけども
姫ありがとうございますよろしくお願いしますということで拒否反応を送っていただい
たんですけど本当に辛いのにトラウマですいません溜めませんでしたしますもうはーい
が温度リフィーナん
俺はもうね量で勝負するしかない今回この4000kcal よ
ん
いい早朝こんなペダ max 食べていきたいとおもいます
今米なんですけども今日1日朝から何も食ってないんでめっちゃ草原って言ってます
じゃあねー
余裕があったら食べますねあっちも実は早速開けてみましょうか
オープンプライスうわーっあっちゃうともう5巻バグってるんだなぁ
あっはずう
スープが青プしっかりありますねあと中身は上側か訳ですね
おう早くですねやいければいけるぞいけるぞ薬入れてゆくはうわー終えが2.2 l
いるのでみなさんお気を付け下さい普通のご家庭だとは多分ケトルに来ないと無理です
ってことはスープのみを指すだけでもだいたいやペットボトル2 l 分呆れてくるっ
てことですねえっ
ん
僕今年を込め禁止1年間よくて今半年経ってるんですけども
小池氏にしてなにがおきたかっていうとラーメンに逃げてるんですよ
ゲイラーニくってるんでめっちゃ今ラーメン体質なんで
いきますね正直イケると思っていますこれぐらいから結構ラーメン屋いって2杯空
ペットバルーンで今のコンディションを泣かせてほしいこのラーメン太一の
コンディション的にはかなり相性がいい相手だと思う
しっかり食べさせていただきますねちょっと開けてみましょうかねぇ
もうワカメが触れるあふれる風呂だってこれも
うわうまツアーそういうラーゲンっぽくなってきたらいやあああ多いなあやっぱり
ちょっと大江などころの話じゃないなできました
サイズか意味分からないですけどなんかお箸とさぁお箸と比べるとわかるけどこれやば
いいですねではいきます
良いスタッフ lost レーサーのエピソードちゃって麺がのびるから本当にワン
ちゃんえいえんにすごい量の女帝だっておい
いうだけに立とれいちゃんでしょアホやん阿呆だ俺はチョップさすが味噌エラグ酸の
ラーメンっていうの中の頭聞こえないんでありがたいです
いただけます
[音楽]
ねぇヤングラーメンあるな2 new 枚数はマジで
いやーこんなもうラーメン好きからしたらたまんないですラーメンの海ですよあの
焼きそばよりキリキリする東承知でちょっと控えめなんで
住め運命めうめ味的には100点満点ですね
味的にはん
まあまあ
山知らないノンストップで7巻くらい食ったんですけどやばいですね普通のラーメン屋
だったらもう4杯ぐらい食ってるイメージ
それちょっと政府ずっと入っていると延々に剃っちゃうんで
全然スープところだねほぼ面も入ったらこれで今週にあの容器に移せば土近深夜取れず
進めていきます
美味しいんです美味しいんです
[音楽]
ん
3分ほど拠点しておりましたあのですねひとついえるのはすごい量の麺がのびちゃって
やばいなんか
取りならず準備してスープから日なぁさせた方が絶対いいです
レジェンド筆てで一生入りません何か良いところと悪いところがあって
焼きそばは水気がないからどんどん食べづらくなってたんですけど
ラーメンは時間経てば経つほど3つ
うってがなくなることはないんですけども a に麺が伸び続ける
延々に
hella
[音楽]
今年ラーメンいいかな結構今なんかから大画面で
埋まってて結構減った方だと思うんですけどまだなんだなぁ
あと伸び続けるのは本当にやばいは成長期か底が知ればもん
[音楽]
ん
すいません冒頭ぜたら30分になってましたああああ
ua 心が折れそういうめっちゃ面の見てんじゃーんな
つるって入るからでか口に入れればなんとかなるみたいな発想でやってます
[音楽]
そこは b 電気はそこはこっからが多いねなんかもう残り少なく見えて全然まで多い
ンってこれらみーこの両よ
1丁9一方ヘッドぎこーゆー時区切った
う
[音楽]
バーサー
多分人間って
3000キロカロリーと1回止まるんだよねもう体が音が無理って言ってますもん
結構も伸びるから食べなきゃじゃあ
[音楽]
えっ
せません1回予報になります容器はなくなりました
でのこれは後コレットこれなんですけどそれらのつとも本当にマジでもぶりなんです
ですねちょっと横にならせください一旦休憩も無理です
ちょっと行け
ちょっと楽になりましたただも2時間は経過してるですねそっともうマジ空はもう勢い
で
しいただきます
[音楽]
もう限界です何かお腹いっぱいとかっていうのが油秒かな
ブラ的なカロリーの限界これは一人でくっついかんな
ん
4日
トゥン
うんはーい多い
例えば na 間に10分58秒でございました
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブー l パッケージ
焼きそばよりかは食べやすかったですねむらんねぇなんで個数スリット入るんですけど
ちょっともうなんかラーメン屋の2杯食べてますとかそういう事を自慢できるレベルで
はないと名前考えでは食べられませんこれは多分2時間で来た相当ヤバいと思うよ
スピード的には多分これ多分相当で味に耐性がないとね脂っこくて食べれないと思うん
で
性命
ちょっと es 暑かったから食べたものの惚れがもしねソースとかだったらもう無理
でも溝無理
ほんと醤油ラーメンだったからことを食べれたような気がします
一人で食うもんじゃないですね相当グリしました
ベアんぐさん
[音楽]
今回も最高でした